hey y'all it's andrew couch here and in
this tidy tuesday video i'm going to
conclude my gg plot 2 video with um a
video on common ggplot2 extensions
so what's really nice about ggplot is
that you can basically create any plot
you want with a little bit of fiddling
but luckily since gg pod has been around
here for a decent amount of time
we've actually had um other people work
on in creating kind of these helper
packages to create some harder plots so
um if you go on the ggplot website you
can click on extensions and they have a
nice little like um official um
page where they have some pretty common
ggpot
libraries i can extend it to more plots
that are easier to create just because
you
um just have to use these simple helper
functions and they're kind of like
verified so they're relatively stable
but as you can see there's you know 100
registered extensions available to
explore uh that's a lot of packages you
know i don't think i even know
if i could name a hundred packages but
um i do use a few packages that i think
are pretty useful
um and i think they're both useful and
you know in a data science and you know
analytics perspective but also if you
are using ggplot to you know do like
data journalism or you know you're
writing an article and you want to
include some cool plots or if you're
doing a lot of presentations um
i have a few packages that are actually
pretty useful to use um in like everyday
um visual data visualizations so
we're going to jump into
our markdown
and the first package i kinda wanna go
over is the gg themes package
so this is just basically like the
themes or the colors of your ggplot
objects and it's very nice um when i was
getting into data visualization i really
used gg themes a lot just because they
had a lot of cool um kind of themes that
you can do um
they borrow from a lot of famous you
know data journals or data of magazines
or whatever
so like things like the economist um 538
um they have like a high charts theme um
i think they might have
maybe they i think they have also like a
tableau theme too
so there's a yeah right here it's taboo
theme so
you know um this type of stuff is
actually very nice because it can make
your plots look so much better with just
simple color coordination
additionally if you have like if you're
working at some organization and they
have you know like a corporate uh color
scheme
you can actually create your own themes
so
i'm not gonna go over creating your own
themes just because
i'm not very interesting you're just
kind of specifying specific like hex
codes for each type of uh you know
component but i'll go over a few of the
uh the themes i think are pretty nice
so let's open up uh
the verse
oops reverse and then we'll do uh gg
themes
cool
so i'm just going to create
i guess a generic plot um
it'll do like ggpot um like a pairwise
scatter
so we'll do that y equals sequel
with and maybe we'll do a color equals
species
so
you know from my previous video about
creating just some simple plots we're
going to create a generic scatter plot
and what we can simply do is add theme
and we use like theme economist
and as you can see it kind of replicates
what the economist charts look like
there are different variations too i
think so there's like a white
one
uh which i think is like their old like
2003 style but
um
yeah so we have a pretty nice chart kind
of looks like the economist
um you can also do a little some other
things so like theme 538 so again
it kind of looks like just a theme
minimal but there's a few variations
with the the coordinates and stuff like
that
um nothing too crazy
so i think uh just looking at themes in
general is actually pretty fun to use
um especially if you want to create some
you know maybe some more centered
products so
you know if you want to maybe make it
our shiny dashboard and kind of have it
replicate tableau you could use these um
help helper functions
but again um it's a pretty
straightforward package i didn't want to
spend too much time on it just because
it's just changing colors there are also
a few different um
add-ons to gg themes i think there's
like a wes anderson palette that you can
download too but
again a pretty good way or pretty fast
way to change your plot and make it look
a little bit nicer or you know kind of a
copycat of uh some other very famous um
new sources
okay
so that's the uh gg themes
another package that i don't really use
too much but it is extremely useful
um if you're doing any plots for like an
article or like a web
or just like a website and stuff like
that um
one common thing that you might run into
is you have a lot of groups and you kind
of want to just plot
one um
one component of that one uh
a once uh item from that group
while keeping everything um together so
right here we have a bunch of types and
say we wanna just you know
isolate one of these types um it's
actually fairly difficult to do it in uh
ggplot
um but luckily we have gg highlight
which basically meant to highlight you
know certain um
visual or certain groups from a ggplot
object so
right here we can just do it right now
um
additionally what it also has this nice
little like end
hit end at this like end label um which
again is you know you can do it with
like a gm label but it requires a lot of
data manipulate data manipulation where
this one you just kind of include it so
uh we'll just do a little overview of
how to do that so
actually i'm gonna
i'm gonna put these packages in here
and when i'm done with this video i'll
put all them commented out so you can
install or download all of them
cool
so we'll do a gg highlight
and with gg highlight i'll just kind of
demonstrate how you uh work with it so i
think we'll just use the uh
i think the economics data set maybe
okay they don't use the economic dataset
but that's fine
um let's say you want to you know plot
out all these components
so we'll do like a pivot
longer
um well did you plot this out first just
to see what it looks like
and i pretty much know what it's gonna
look like because we don't we're not on
the same scale
um because we're kind of inadvertently
doing this um
so what we can do is group it by the
name
and just scale it
so
a value is equal to scale
value
and then we can do it on group
okay
so we have our uh our economic
components
um now what we just need to do is add
gg highlight and with gg highlight
here you can see that uh you're
essentially just saying like what groups
you want to filter in so in this case we
can filter in like give it a list of
values
for the name so let's go to that
we'll say plus gg highlight
i'll say name is equal to
uh
i don't know on and
what
right but then it kind of grays
everything out uh and then it colors out
the thing you want to do
i wonder if they're if you can you i
wonder if you can do a list so let's see
if you can do that
so name is in
unemploy
and
i am
on was it e u e m
e m e d
yup so you can do like list so
essentially what you're doing is like
filtering what you want to highlight
um
again uh very useful plot thick uh very
useful package to use um i think there
are some ways to kind of customize you
know the highlighting and the opacity of
it
um
but again i'm just going through it we
can see you know it's not just just line
charts you can do it with basically any
other gm or ggplot object
um
yeah uh you can also say use direct
label goes false stuff like that
again don't want to go
too deep into it because i still think
it's a pretty simple package
um but
uh again it's a very useful um
uh package to do when you're creating
some like isolated plots or you wanna
like highlight something
uh which explains the name
um you can do it by calculate for fast
and you know there is some watch that
goes into it
um but you know that's definitely kind
of domain specific for your problem
okay cool
um i also want to go over a few packages
that i use probably a decent amount and
i've also used in
uh past videos and it's gonna be gg ally
um gg ally is probably one of my
favorite packages that
i use i definitely use it basically
every time i do some type of eda and i'm
like pulling from some database and i
kind of want to see you know just the
overall relationship of the data points
and instead of you know going
uh and creating a bunch of redundant
plots um gg ally kind of has our backs
and we can just do like gg duo
um give it the iris data set
and it'll basically do the plotting for
us for like at least common things so
air wise
it's essentially pairwise plots so it's
smart enough to understand you know
discrete and continuous variables so
um we can see how obviously it's like a
pair it's like a correlation matrix so
we have like steeple length compared to
steeple length we expect one-to-one
correlation and we can see the rolling
ships are right here
they throw a nice little like gm smooth
i'm assuming using like lowest um you
can change that too with a different
settings
um
but as we look at in the species we can
see that you know uh it's able to make
the distribution of the plot so we can
see like hey uh e species um when we
actually
go up here and expand it
yep so we can see how you know
we have setosa versus color oh actually
you can't see it but setosa versus color
and virginica um and see how the you
know the distribution is different space
uh different uh simple links you know
there's obviously uh the length of it
kind of dictates the species
um there's another one called gg pairs
which does a similar thing uh because it
still does like the pairwise um
interactions but
uh we can see that there's a few more
like statistical stuff so we get some
summary statistics from it uh we see the
distribution of the data
uh we can still see our scatter plots
showing the relationships but we also
get some correlation
components
right and obviously we still have the
histograms
um
so gdli also has you know a few other
things we have kind of a scat mat
which is for only continuous variables
so you know you can kind of customize
uh the gg uh the gg ally objects
stuff like that so there is definitely a
bunch of comparisons we can do
um in this case i think they do uh
there's a yeah there isn't you can do
some you know
um customization on it
um for me i usually don't
uh show people these plots
like for presentations just because you
know there's a lot of information that's
being brought up i mostly do it to kind
of like isolate things i want to look
deeper into
um
i think there's one more thing that i i
think is somewhat useful
um but i'm not sure if i can get it so
where is it oh yeah gg bivariate let's
see if we have any bivariate data
um
yeah i think that
it's
one variable name okay
maybe i can do this with
gg by
variate
um the iris data set outcome
equals
species
i do it
um how do i do this
okay
right so we can kind of see
uh something so if we're trying to
predict uh
you know make a model we can use gg by
variant to kind of get these uh
interactions between the predict the
thing we want to predict and the
the uh features so if you're doing some
like cattle competitions or like i guess
what was sliced i think slice is over
now that would have been kind of a
useful function to use when you want to
pick out you know some features to use
for a model
cool
um again there are a lot of functions in
here uh i definitely don't know all of
them i've seen some with like gg
coefficients but now that we have tidy
models um we kind of have some ways that
we can plot out
our model like results or model features
using the vip package but you know if
you
want to do more like linear models i
think or glms this can give you it
again not too bad um there are some
network plots i've never really used
them too much but
um i've always used the i think the imap
package but you know
you can still do that
but again uh there's a lot of things
that we can do with gg ally and uh
it's pretty nice to use uh you can
customize and get very like a large
amount of plots with literally like one
line of code
which would require which would actually
taking like 10 minutes to actually plot
out if it wanted to do all this stuff so
very useful function makes things very
fast
for your like data science workflow
cool
uh
let's see here
here
so um another package that i really like
using i actually use this package a lot
now since i've been working
uh is the gigi ridges package
and uh they used to be called like i
think joy division plots um but now we
call them like ridgeline plots um and
it's sensory it's essentially like a gm
density but we can kind of facet it um
on the y-axis
so this is pretty good um
let's actually go over it so library
oops
uh library and we'll say gg ridges
uh okay
oh
uh
i don't know what what do i want to do
uh
i guess we'll do the iris data set so we
can just do a uh
uh we'll just shut here
mutate across
species
you know scale scale
scale it
uh multicross
okay
i just want to scale these variables so
uh
title dot width
oh
mutate up was it
across uh where
or i think i said is numeric and then i
can do scale cool
um and then we'll do a pivot
longer
actually i didn't really need it minus
i think i really didn't need to do all
that but again different way to skin a
cat
so in this case we want to do our value
and if we just do this or we say like
color equals name
and do a gm
density
we can see that they're stacked
in the stack by name we can see the
color of each uh
distribution uh what we just need to do
is switch out to y equals name
and then we'll say density
and say like ridges right
and now we have our our uh ridgeline
plot
um you can also say like i think color
is equal to species
or fill
syllable species and we can now see
actually a pretty interesting plot
comparing you know all of our features
with our uh the just the distribution of
things that we you know want to predict
or at least the species right now
and i actually use this a lot um for me
this is actually useful when we're
plotting out like um simulations and
looking at the distribution of outcomes
for me i also do it i'll use gigi ridges
a lot with uh bayesian analysis so when
i'm using the brms package and getting a
posterior distribution
uh i can basically plot out the
distribution of my parameters
um
that's actually very useful for me
because i can kind of show people the
uncertainty of some effects and some of
the model outcomes
so for me i actually use it a lot um i
also think it's a pretty sweet looking
uh
plot
um there are some few things that we can
do like you get you can add um
you can do like a gradient too like that
um you just kind of have to change the
the
you know some of the scale so maybe i
can do it right here where i can do uh
the phyllis species we'll just do that
and then what is it
let's say fill equals yes
so instead of saying the fill equals
like the value we just say we have to
say stats
uh value
uh
and then we have to do gm
um density
bridges
radians right
so now we have a nice little gradient
and then we can do like a skill for this
right
um one thing i'm actually interested
maybe we could do like a uh
like we could
we could use uh
oh what the
one thing we can also do i think is add
like you know a theme so we can say
theme uh
i don't know
wall street journal i wonder if that'll
mess everything up so we have wall
street journal i think that actually
looks pretty bad so we'll use 538
right so 538 plot again doesn't really
locate 538 pot just because it's just
you know the same colors but
right
uh we can see how
um we can combine a lot of these other
packages with each other uh since
they're all just gg pot objects they can
interact well with each other pretty
quickly
um let me go back here there is another
plot where we can create
um what's called like uh
what's called like uh rain cloud plots
uh let me see where it's at
um yeah so we can do like rain cloud
plots where you can basically uh plot
the gm rug underneath it
um i think it actually makes the plot
kind of busy you also make a cheese pot
which is very funny but i think
isn't a good plot um
so you can do that um yeah you just have
to add in this thing
uh so as you can see that you know for
me
i'm perfectly fine with
copy and pasting because there did the
work for me so we can see how we have
like the distribution of it or whatever
um again i don't really like it but some
people might so
i'm actually delete that or i'll comment
i'll comment it out
all right
comment this control shift c to comment
uh chunk
oh no ha ha someone we now have the uh
plot so i'll say uh values
cool
so um obviously this still is a simple
plot uh or a simple package we we're
just using you know gm density ridges it
basically acts as gm density but we have
you know a few more um primers that we
can adjust
to make the pot look a little bit nicer
cool
um yeah actually i kind of like that pot
that's actually not too bad um
but we can actually go to the next plot
next few packages um and these packages
uh basically go around text i know we
went over
um some themes some highlighting which
kind of uses like gm label but i think
actually working with tech date or
working with text in general with ggpod
is probably the weakest feature of it
um
so let me actually work with this
um i think we'll use the mt cards
because i think they use that as a
thing so i'll say
was it row names
equals um i think that's a model
yeah cool
so now we have like some
bots we have like some i think car
um stuff so we'll just say
let's do y equals i don't know
horsepower
i don't know anything about cars so
um
we just want to create a simple plot of
miles per gallon
cool so we have miles per gallon
horsepower and then we would want to add
our car models so in this case we'll say
label is equal to model
and then we'll do like a gm
label
and we can see that it's not doing what
we really want it to do
right there's so many overlapping labels
um they're kind of they're also over the
point which is annoying so we don't
really know what this maserati bora it
really is if it's like on 15
and stuff like that since the text is
like that
luckily we have what's called uh
gg repel
and this basically solves the problem
with gm label
which repels the text
so we can do that
right here we'll say
library gg repel
and then we'll do the same thing
but what's nice about this is we just
say gm
label repel
and we can see that it's like repelled
out we can see that you know it
automatically adds these lines
um it is adjustable
so we can uh go back here
um gm label repel and as you see there
are so many ways to adjust it you can do
padding you can do the min segment
length so if i want to have lines for
everything i think i just say
min dot segment length equals like i
don't know one
or
zero and then i'll
remove it so yeah zero so we have all
these um labels
um again pretty useful um
if you don't like the labels you can do
gm text repel
right so they're kind of right next to
each other maybe we can say like
i make it ridiculous or
okay
so zero
there are also ways that we can
basically force the labels to be at a
certain point
i think they have pretty good examples
in here
um right so you can do uh tm text repel
and then add another data point where
you know you're kind of isolating it
um where's the the example
um yeah you can do some nudge with
we can do some nudging too so we have
this nice like was it a parallel plot
and stuff like that you can also add
like little curves
um with segment curvature
so i don't really want to go through all
those parameters again
it's kind of useful but for me to go
over and like do these fine adjustments
it's like 10 minutes of me adjusting you
know things like 0.1 or 0.2
not very interesting for this video and
i want to make this video pretty fast
so
the next package is the gg text package
um i use this this package mostly to do
some
adjustments to like the title
because it allows us to do some i think
like html formatting on it so it's
actually hard to get like
um so for example this like when we're
plotting out like a bar chart
sometimes people like it when we have
the bar charts axis labels to correspond
with the color
um
and it's actually not pop i don't think
it's possible to do it in ggpot uh
natively so you have to use the gg text
package
so we'll just do that gg text
and i'll do the same thing with iris so
i'll do
species y equals
people dot length
and box plot
and i'll do a except for have to do
color so i'll say color is equal to
specie
right
cool
so what we can do is just add our labs
so i'll say title is equal to like
comparing
uh
setosa
[Music]
right and what we can do is we can
basically use
uh the uh
the html format to customize our text
in this case i just kind of copy and
paste it because i don't want to type
everything out
it's just a span okay
we'll just do that
right and what this is saying is like
this is our html thing anything in
between
these two spans so this thing is like we
want to change that color
um
uh so we'll just say was it
dosa
and then we'll say versus color
virginica versus color is green
and blue
[Music]
and then i'll just copy and paste this
in
verse of color
green setosa
okay
cool
and one thing we have to do
is add in um
this thing right here since we're
changing our title
we just have to add in
the element text box simple and that's a
way for it to i think like
um
kind of uh
say to the plot that we're we're going
to be assessing the text from like a
different uh
we're going to assess the text using
html instead of gg fos like native way
to interpret it so
as you see you know comparing setosa
versacar and virginica um the colors
aren't matched perfectly we can use like
hex codes but i don't really know the
hex codes for um that gtpot's default
colors so that's something you might
want to look up um maybe i'll i'll write
it down um when i upload this video
but um that's basically what i use tgg
text for again if you're like a data
journalism and you're a data journalist
and you're creating a plot
i think most of the time people will
just create the plot and then they'll
actually do the fine tuning of the text
and stuff like that and like adobe
illustrator or some type of other you
know actual photoshop thing
same with the lines and stuff like that
um at least that's what i've learned
when i was um listening onto a zoom call
with like 538 data journalists
so
um yeah
um i hope you guys like this video i
know i went kind of fast but
i think these packages are pretty useful
um for someone who's starting out using
ggplot
they are very useful for you know not
just data scientists and analysts but
also people who you know are just
working with data in general so
definitely look into it one interesting
thing i do think is a good way to
practice ggpot though is basically
creating these plots um using you know
based based gigipot instead of using
these helper packages so that's a good
way to practice on plotting so one way
to do is like you know we'll just create
this plot create this plot for this spot
when you're starting out and kind of see
how they interact with each other
so
uh that's it for this video um i'm am
gonna start recording the time series
video on forecasting so i'm pretty
excited for that but
until then i'll see you as next time and
teddy on